If I didn't go about teaching my children
tradition
and culture, it would be a whole gap
and we might not be able to give back.
Then my family would be lost in tradition
and culture.
That little spot back here,
just there, Beaver Dam blocking it
but there's enough water flowing over it
to where we can jump it.
[inaudible] Can we do that again?
No, hell no.
This boat that I got last year,
I was able to sell
a bunch of mammoth ivory,
buy a nice big 150 motor,
and it's got a jet on there. I’m
able to drive in some pretty skinny water.
This boat is especially designed
for smaller numbers up here in Allakaket
Oh, he's hunting just like us.
Oh a little calf.
Two Calves!
Future generations food right there.
Now, someday
my kids might be hunting those calves
when they're nice, big, strong bulls.
All right,
Wow! We don't shoot swans when they're
paired up like that, they mate for life.
You kill one of them.
That other one is just going to fly around
and quit eating
and just die of a broken heart.
That's a happily married couple.
I don't want to jump in between that.
I think we've been out for at least
24 hours.
I'm not totally sure.
Hard to tell
when the sun doesn't really go down.
We're just going to keep on trying.
It'll open up wider here pretty quick.
Uh oh.
We really got to get up some speed
to get over this next dam.
I don’t know about this.
Well, trying to rip some of the sticks
out of this beaver dam.
Having the kids out in the boat,
it is a safety hazard.
This is springtime,
the rivers are just right above freezing.
You've got a lot of water
and they get a lot of water
and they get heavy
and they start flowing really fast.
And if we can get some speed,
we can make it through it,
I’m sure.
Whoa!
[inaudible]
That was pretty wild.
We made it. Woo!
Hard times don't last forever.
Strong people do though.
See him?
Yea.
Go ahead, Terry.
Good shot.
Thanks.
Canvas back!
Oh!
We’re 300 miles away from the ocean.
We get to eat something from the ocean.
It's pretty special.